you're a disaffected liberal is that
fair to say I think that's very
extremely fair to say why I was hoping
you guys would tell
me you know what's great about you and I
we both look liberal and we both look
visibly
disaffected there are decisions that I
think every human being makes or comes
to that are in my internal Supreme Court
a 5 to four decision I think that's the
thing that people won't acknowledge
Neil we interviewed Bill Maher a couple
of days ago and one of the things we
were saying to him is how much we
respect the fact that he sticks to the
ethos that we always thought was the
ethos of Comedy which is you make fun of
both sides MH uh you don't go oh those
guys over there that we hate let's just
bang on about how evil they are
endlessly but you actually make fun of
both sides and blocks your later special
does that incredibly well is that
something you were conscious of when you
were doing that is that something that
is kind kind of a thing that you think
about or is it just something that comes
naturally uh I think the jokes
come uh involuntarily and
then and then I I don't go well I'm
going to be
losing I don't want to lose CU I've
realized something I the older I get the
more I realize like you never have the
group anyway especially liberals you
never have them there's no they the
goalpost keep moving so
you're the purity test gets pure and
purer so there's no point
in courting them because there's no
loyalty I don't now having said that I
think there is more loyalty on the right
but I don't believe a lot like you know
what I mean like I just don't agree
with the I'm I'm like I I'm I'm oriented
to the left you're a disaffected liberal
is that fair to say I think that's very
extremely fair to say uh yeah no I was
going to say why
um I was hoping you guys would tell me
uh uh I think the the as I stated
there's not a ton of loyalty there's
it's the it's all the old arguments the
circular firing squad the uh the they'd
rather attack you know an impure liberal
than than a a just a super farri person
um
and there's blind spots that on both
sides and I
think knowing more liberals than than
conservatives they just blinded them you
know yeah that's the thing that I find
frustrating as someone who would call
themselves a disaffected liberal as well
that's the thing that I struggle with
you know what's great about you and I we
both look liberal and we both look
visibly
disaffected are you saying I've got
right wing Vibes you well the Blazer's
not doing you a ton
of that is true that is true it's the
centrus Blazer drags me to the midd we
just look sad is what I'm trying to say
we look like we're waiting for the blur
concert to start yeah we do we do we
just we you know this is I think this is
you know what part of it is Neil I've
got Irish heritage and I've got Latino
Heritage and when you've got Irish you
get pale you get sad doesn't matter what
you mix it with you sure do you drink
and you drink or then and then you stop
drinking thank you but but it's
interesting what what you were saying
because it's the blind spots that I find
frustrating not that you believe a
certain thing because if you believe a
certain thing then great believe a
certain thing whatever it is but it's
the blind spots I'm like can you not see
this yeah it just it's defensiveness
isn't attractive on anybody and and
especially ideological
defensiveness and uh and and so it's
just this it became I think in the age
of social media as well it became more
people became more and more intractable
in
their points of view and then it became
if they could dunk on you then it was
settled and it's like no this is a fixed
fight this is a fixed fight it's a I
have a term for it which is a uh Putin
karate tournament you ever see Putin do
karate seems fixed doesn't
it where he's just flipping people over
and just like so there the most of the
internet is a is a Putin's karate
tournament and and uh and but and then
everybody gets in their their silos and
it's just it and then it's just a pure
diet of of of confirmation bias and it
it's it's I feel like it's kind of
stopped a little bit but it was it was
heading hard in one direction for 13
years probably yeah in my intimation and
I think one of the reasons that I I'm
certainly disaffected is when I was I
don't know how old you I'm 40 when I was
talk I don't talk about it I wouldn't um
when I was growing up it was the
religious right who all the comedians
that I respected car and H were making
fun of and the reason was those were the
people who were saying can't say that
can't do this can't have this opinion
don't don't use that word you know
hicks's last letman monologue was
censored he was not published for over a
decade I think because he made fun of
religious people right so they were
quote unquote the bad guys for comedians
for people who believe that expression
is important for people who believe in
the ability to joke and take the piss as
we say Etc and so the reason I'm
disaffected is was like then it flipped
and now the people going you can't say
this you can't do that are like our team
if you like I still think it's I think
still think it's I think it's still the
religious right and now the left also
the religious left I don't even think
it's yes precisely I have a
Hicks observation I'm you'll meet no
bigger Hicks fan than me saw him live
introduce Dave Chappelle to Bill Hicks
Dave said he's never seen me more
nervous it was like 1992 or three
um that joke about uh American
Gladiators where he says watch these
pituary
retards pituary is not a word he meant
pituitary MH and it's a tragedy
that he said that in public he just was
misusing a word publicly one of the
smartest comedians ever um neither here
nor there uh the it is now it's it's the
thing where now uh you know the left is
advocating um not saying misgendering or
what you can't misgender people that's
just one example and the right's still
trying to ban books so it's both sides
uh to me that are both still
doing um all of the things that are easy
to make fun of and they they're just
Banning different books they're both
Banning different books you know when
you say Banning books what do you mean
because I'm not like the like the on the
right wanting to not uh in Florida
getting rid of all the Dei curriculum
and whatever you can call it Banning
books or you can call it uh they don't
want that type of stuff published or
taught well taught and published are
very different things right like Banning
something for you know not reading mind
Camp to 5-year-olds is not Banning the
book it's it's how you decide what the
education system teaches people right
yeah so I I I that's why I always sort
of I'm not sure that they are Banning
books exactly but I know what you mean
there's you know what I mean though
there is a there's a desire for
restriction and censorship on on every
side particularly towards the extremes
yes yeah I see what you're saying but
and it the thing that also that I find
frustrating and worrying actually is a
much better word is we've kind of things
have kind of settled down now they've
kind of we we hit a peak during the
Trump years and now they're starting to
settle to settle people are starting to
become less entrenched people there's a
modicum of common sense being injected
into the
discourse it's less insane but then I
look over the horizon and I see 2024 and
I'm going holy it's going to get
bad again heat up your hot takes fellas
cuz we are going to need them uh I think
it will be
insane I think it will
be less insane than it's been because I
think people thought that there was
going to be some Promised Land of of uh
like we'll just settle these arguments
and I'll expend a ton of energy on this
on arguing online and all this stuff and
then we'll all figure it out and we can
go back to life as we knew it and what
they realized is the arguments were not
settled and all you can kind of do is
like divest yourself a little bit of the
intensity and like I I just got to go on
Twitter l or just coming to like
personal decisions of like I I you know
people now are saying when they say I
got into an argument on Twitter it's
with a sense of Shame now or a of
exhaustion and like I can't
believe it I did it again whereas before
it was like I got an an argument can I
show you and it was it was more proud
and righteous and now it's it seems a
little bit more exhausted because we're
starting I think more and more we're
starting to understand Neil that
actually social media isn't good for us
whereas before because it was so brand
new I'm holding out hope oh I want it no
yeah of course it was Brandon we thought
there was
some Bounty awaiting us if we won that
argument like it would be settled and
it's just not never going to be it's
like all technology it has I mean social
media is brilliant and it's
terrible yes that's what it is
and so like many things you know we
interviewed Tom Bilu from Impact Theory
yesterday I don't know if you're
familiar with him but he he said
something that really CH first of all
explained why we started the show but
also just gave a frame for how to think
about these things he was saying I
believe we need a creative tension
between different sides on many issues
and right and whatever else it might be
and that's why you know talking about
the cist Blazer like that's what I
always thought the left has some good
ideas the right has some good ideas uh
they both have some terrible ideas
particularly at the extremes how do we
kind of synthesize from different sides
but we have been pushed apart and that
Center ground where the good stuff
happens that is less and less populated
now do you would you I the the thing
that on coming here I was thinking about
like
not like I like Neil you need to decide
who you
are this is a once and for all there are
decisions that I think every human being
makes or comes to that
are in my internal Supreme Court a five
to four
decision there are no unanimous
decisions there are things where I am
53% for 47% against but I have to vote
in favor of of the 53 and and I think
that's the thing that people won't
acknowledge yeah like that that we are
living especially
now society's so transparent our lives
are so transparent it was easier before
when we just didn't know anything I'm
doing a joke where I'm like it was
better before documentaries cuz we could
say stuff like yeah the whale wants to
be at SeaWorld yeah
and then you go then all these
documentaries there's footage of
everything everyone's trackable so now
we know
everyone's hypocrisies including
ourselves so and you guys probably know
firsthand the more aware you are or if
you grew up in the church or whatever in
Catholic church with like I did like the
more aware people are of their own
hypocrisies the more they'll cover it up
and no no no no no and shove it down and
so I'm kind of comfortable now just
saying like I am a hypocrite in a
hypocrite in a lot of ways and I'm happy
to make fun of them and you know even
the if you get to like take abortion for
instance if you get down to the core
argument it's like when does Life
Begin that's a pretty big
question huh so it's like the heartbeat
okay how'd you come to that how does it
once you start asking asking follow-ups
so many arguments fall apart and I think
prior to social
media uh and the in a transparent
basically a transparent Society we were
more comfortable just accepting like yep
I'm pro-choice or I'm pro-life or
whatever and then you get into the
specifics of anything and it's it's you
just go yeah I'm barely I'm this but not
by a ton and that's such a great point
because I think that's one of the
problems of our age is the death of
nuance like people wanting to pretend
very complex very serious issues are
relatively simple and you're like come
on man if it was relatively simple
wouldn't we have solved this wouldn't we
have gone oh we just need to do this and
then move on to the next thing yeah I
and and even and and I also as a
comedian I I know people with wildly
Divergent opinions uh and all always
have and it's are you funny are you nice
great it's like it's I've been friends
with Joe Rogan for 30 years and and
sometimes people on the left would be
like how and I'm like cuz he's
funny and nice yeah and and like has
helped like did was nice to me when I
was a door man at a comedy club had no
reason to be other than just like I like
this guy he likes him whatever he was he
did Chappelle Show before was popular he
he's had me on his podcast a dozen time
like I
don't I'm not I'm I'm less
uh apt to want to sort of dismiss or or
or throw people away because I know that
everyone's opinion isn't maybe he's got
a 55 45 opinion that we disagree it's
not a blowout it's like that's what
that's where he ended up and and I can
accept it as a human being who has his
own
process to accept that other people ran
their process and that's the decision
they came to and also as well if you're
going to be one of those people who
ditches people which is a lovely way of
putting I would like to say I have
ditched people I don't want to say like
I've never I have yeah and I kind of
regret it yeah why did you sorry FR I
think that's a good followup why did you
ditch people and why do you regret it
because when things are
fevered during an election or during a
big you know a big uh Supreme Court
decision or January 6 or whatever you
start to feel like these are
uh like Primal life and death
existential yeah yeah um and and you
start to go like I must there was also
this thing of of it felt like or or Co
where we had to if you believe this then
you believe all these other things that
I can't countenance I cannot accept that
in you
and it's just it's I so I would make DEC
again not a ton and I can't even think
of any specifics but but I know I have
so I don't I want to cover myself um and
and that you you feel like it's the
noble thing to do you know it's the
noble for my ethics Meanwhile my ethics
are paper
thing and why do you regret
it cuz it's
childish it's childish it's just a
childish way to to to uh
approach you know nothing well not
nothing is that important but but it's
it's it's a it speaks for lack of
maturity on my part and what it also
doesn't acknowledge is how precious
friendship is yeah that's a big one I
mean that's another big one where it's
like like I said about Joe Joe's not
even a yeah it's like cuz they're not
like
it's interesting in this sort of sort of
Scarlet Letter time of like ah you
know the thing that that people a value
that totally got lost was loyalty yeah
the value
of like no I like this person they've
been kind to me they've helped me I
can't now just immediately turn my back
cuz cuz uh you know whatever what
whatever small infraction it is um and
and there's also that thing with the
with the me too stuff where it's hard to
know how to you you risk If you defend
somebody uh or even defend their right
to like a fair hearing right then you're
anti-
the other side you know whether you're
like I believe this woman well are you
saying that it's a rush to judgment on
about the guy okay and if you say I
stand with the guy's right to then
you're you you're you hate all women I
me we had this with in um with the when
he got me too exactly and I came out and
we quashed not guilty yes exactly that's
not exactly what they say right no no no
no no no the lack of evidence but um but
and also as well just talking about how
precious friendship is we live in a
world now where we're on online more and
more and more friendship especially in
real life just seems to be
receding and what happened to yeah I
mean he could look he's a bit of a dick
about this but he's a great guy I think
computers meaning I don't think that
there's much who needs friends it's the
it's I so I think it was an onion
article or somebody where it was it was
uh people can't have three minute phone
conversations but can listen to two-hour
podcasts that's
somehow no that's easy you know but like
just the getting on the when someone
calls you then you're like what you know
whereas and you guys release a podcast
we all know and we're all waiting just
we're hitting refresh um but but
seriously like there there is less of a
in-person
it's not a product people want anymore
uh like an in-person relationship is
less necessary in the age of I can get
my exact order delivered to my exact
location and I don't get challenged in
any way I don't get uh I don't get sort
of app you don't get any human
interaction but one of the main ones I
don't get challenged I don't get
inconvenience I don't have to shower I
don't have to do all the stuff that's a
a bit of a a bit of an inconvenience I
think our brains make it like a huge
inconvenience you just imagine it is way
worse than it is so I think
the the it is there is a weird thing
where it's a lack
of we feel like there's lack of a
necessity for friendship it's
interesting you say that because I know
that I think podcasts show that the
opposite is also true and but two things
can be true at once right uh we have a
mutual friend I don't
agree we have a mutual friend where like
I disagree with them a lot more than you
do probably and we have such a great
time because the that's interesting to
me talking to interesting people who
think about things in a complex way who
don't agree with me and we talk for
hours and likewise with lots of other
people and I think the reason people
enjoy podcast is you know we have uh
people who watch our show who like we
watched that episode and then I sat down
with my husband and we talked about it
for two hours yeah you know there is
something to be said for uh I believe a
guy named Jonathan Solomon a comedian in
the 80s and 90s did a joke
about uh Cosmo magazine being the
Playbook of the enemy and and it was
just like a good it's like a good
observation like women's magazines like
what are these what are these crazy
people thinking right um there is
something to be said
for what is the other side thing it's
also fun having a friend that is on the
other side so to speak and you guys talk
about your own side with each other
like oh yeah you're totally right about
like what is that person thing so that's
enjoyable and also it can
be entertain it's entertaining like it's
just if somebody's got a if somebody
thinks that Hillary Clinton is a vampire
or whatever and and they can show me a
good joke about it I don't think Hillary
Clinton's a vampire but I if you do I
can see why that's funny and therefore I
can kind of get in I think it's funny
now because I part of it is I think your
point of view is ridiculous but this is
a good illustration of it like I love
the Babylon be I don't agree with them
politically but like ComEd I've done
their pocket like comedically those guys
I send those articles as I send those
links as much as any other comedy
other than the onion it's like one in
one a in terms of like look at
this joke this is good joke
there is there is something really
delicious
about someone trashing your side or your
belief so I really enjoy like when I was
watching blocks as a disaffected liberal
the joke about you know you're a
conservative welcome you go to a group
of liberals we'll see yeah yeah yes
that's the the maybe the worst telling
of that joke I know I was going to say
but please please cut to a clip
I'm begging you I'll clear it with
Netflix I'll call Ted Sandos myself a
conservative goes to a group of
conservatives they say welcome a liberal
goes to a group of liberals they say
we'll see yes and yes and i' I also
butchered it because I we'll insert
the clip let's just insert the now I'm
afraid I'm not even going to tell
because I'm afraid I'll it up like
it's going to be
contagiously you're going to you're
getting a you started this no Neil's
comedy is brilliant it's much better
than it's much better than slightly
better yeah the problem being liberal is
there's no amount of liberal that's ever
liberal enough like if there's a bunch
of Republicans standing around and
someone comes up and goes hey I'm a
republican they go like come on in if
there's a bunch of liberals standing
around a liberal comes up and goes hey
I'm liberal they're like we'll
see you can believe the right is a
liberal but if you express it
incorrectly you're it's
terrifying you ever try to talk about
like transgender issues in public
even right now you're like we don't got
to do this
Neil don't go out like your boy just
move
on but that's exactly my point it's
terrifying like I'm sure we all believe
the right but you ever try you try
to talk about transgender issues in
public is like playing conversational
Jenga where you're
like PR SS he they and the Republicans
are like so we'll call them
yeah it there is no I I
understand uh Gavin Nome joke like I get
what if I was not liberal I would
understand how loath some people find
Gavin Nome or or Nancy Pelosi or or uh
what who was the corpse the corpse who
finally no that's the other corpse um
the uh yeah I've been doing a joke that
we they going to get we they going to be
led by Trump from jail or Biden from
hospice and that's just where we are as
a country um yeah like I like admitting
that Biden's incred wildly old
you know what I mean like admitting that
barbar is that no it wasn't who was the
lady who just died like a month ago fste
yeah she wouldn't give it up so so it
mitting like I and not pretending it's
in any way
uh cool I think you just go yeah Biden's
a corpse but I'm going to vote for
him because I I don't care what the
president looks like or even how he
walks I need the votes that's my point
of view on it I don't see it as like a
leadership position as like the Optics S
I just don't that just doesn't speak to
me and what does that say new about
American societ because you look at
America you go you've got all these
great thinkers you got some of the best
colleges in the world you've got all
these amazing people here and you go
that's the best you can give
me um yeah
it's it's funny because I I think of
like a young someone
under 55 couldn't win because they have
too much in public you know what I
mean like it's going to have to take
that generation like people over 60 to
die and then it'll be a bunch of
candidates with with Dick
piics and uh controversial old tweets
and it it'll just have to be like a
mutually sure destruction thing where
where it was kind of like when everyone
knew Bush did Coke but there was even
with the media that were kind of
like what I think it's going to get to
that point I hope or or I don't even if
I hope I don't know if it's better I I'd
say that's where we're going but we just
got to run out of old people first kind
of yeah or like people that believe in
that those sort of or even Obama said he
did like so it just became this thing of
like what's
permissible um for a candidate and what
does this whole environment do for
comedy is this like a really good time
do you feel I think it's a good time I
don't look all even all my friends who
have gotten cancelled are doing Arenas m
so so I'm not I wouldn't cry for
Chappelle or Rogan or Tom or any of
these like or any of these guys are all
these guys are doing incredibly well and
the
tension is fun to me to me it's fun it's
fun it's like the there's more lasers
and you kind of have to you know get
around them in a clever way you know
than then then uh just kind of or or not
or you can just say whatever you want
and deal with the deal there the
backlash seems to be I think the
backlashers realize like this is useless
and they're creating popularity for the
people making Stars I suppose the one
question I always think about is that's
definitely true for you and if someone
wants to try and cancel us it will be
true for us is that true for a new comic
who's sort of making their way up
I mean I think Shane Gillis uh is a good
example of U somebody who used
the uh cancel his cancellation as a
jiujitsu um and as a springboard like oh
you never heard of me and I'm now the
guy who did a Chinese a offensive
Chinese accent that that every single
human being alive has done and then
Chinese people have done a different Act
Chinese people have done Indian and then
everyone has their accent that they
secretly do um
so so I don't I see it as like I don't
worry about the young the Next
Generation because I don't think that
there's much of
a there I I don't think it worked I just
don't think it was like a I I don't I
think it I don't know if it totally
backfired but it's just you're just
creating you just was a form of like you
know Star Search or something well this
is what I say you know in terms of
cancel culture what the way to defeat it
is to go oh you try to cancel somebody
well they're bigger now you know and
then eventually I mean these people are
quite slow but eventually they'll work
out this isn't what you do yeah I think
well it hasn't happened in it hasn't
happened since Dave Chappelle with the
Trans stuff so I think and they they
kind
of I I don't know if they would anyone
would consider that a success no no I
don't think no Dave probably
does right your girlfriend yeah I was
going to say actually so could you make
the Chappelle show now on TV by the way
Chappelle Show is your used to be a
teacher you're used to be
teacher you really do watch trigonometry
it's going to come up um do you know
he's from
Venezuela uh I don't know what the
that has to do with any he says it every
other episode oh is that the other one
I only have two's not as big a fan as we
are no I know I you caught me
that's all gotta um we'll be right back
um uh
yeah I don't know it's one of those
things
where uh I don't want to say like we
couldn't do it
today um I think it would
be a bigger pain in the ass cuz for all
of of the as much as I say like cancel
culture doesn't
work I would say it's taxing on a
person's Spirit um whether you're Dave
or Joe or
or you know Shane yis or whatever it it
you get through it but it is like I
think it's a bit of like a um and that
would have
been there was not much of a the only
barometer for like should we do this was
personal it wasn't we there was no worry
about so and so is going to come down
and it was more just like do you want to
is that a thing that's worth is that an
idea that's worth promoting yeah you
know you know there are some Comics who
say actually they like those lasers now
being in place I agree that's what I
mean I I would say I'm one of those
Comics cuz it it's certainly like you
know uh uh
separates I was going to say men from
the boys feels like you can't say that
anymore I don't and I don't even know
why I don't know why you can't say that
anymore but I don't think you can I just
it feels bad yeah it's cuz we're sitting
in La yeah there you go that's why
that's why do you ever feel like there's
I know you get the sense of lasers and
that was so beautiful about blocks is
that it felt like a comedian who's at
the top of their game tap dancing around
the lasers but do you ever cuz we've
spoken to people about this in Liberal
Comics as well who say that it kind of
influences their writing somewhat like
they find themselves cens self
censoring as opposed to a more vert like
you can't say that from person over
there I yeah it that's what I mean it
ends up being you you even the cancel
culture it does the Spectre of it exists
I don't
it's not a ton of stuff that I'm like
dying to say there are some words that
are not very acceptable anymore that I
I'm going to be honest with you I miss
uh it was
yeah we all miss great word it's
a great word a Rogan has a great bit
about this how like people have lost and
this is something I wanted to talk to
you about which is people have lost
their abil
retards retards have lost their ability
to understand context and his point is
when you've got somebody saying that to
a 5-year-old mentally handicapped kid
that's unacceptable but if
you're saying it about a guy in his 4S
who thinks the Earth is flat is perfect
yeah I yeah I would agree with that um
so and that's part of that's why I
missed it that's why I miss it um is be
it's just an effective tool yeah you
know and it's so you just go you're oh
look at this neurode Divergent
you just have to like Doug
Doug St up used to do a bit about where
it just moves on yeah because at one
point was the clean word it was
like the substitute word and they just
pie they just evolve um and and so so I
don't I I miss it but again it's like
all right I'll get another tool yeah
I'll say neurod Divergent
and everyone will hear do you
think the lasers make you better make
you more skilled now you're having to
kind of Bob and we a little know maybe I
it's uh I will say tension helps comedy
so I let's say it does make it more more
it makes it it's there there's more
tension so if you can hit it right um
that was the great thing the jokes and
blocks that I like doing was like most
of my crowd is liberal so like making
fun of abortion and guns and and the
Purity tests and all that stuff was and
hearing them laugh was it was was like
okay so you're I'm not alone in in
recognizing this so I think the
tension is useful overall in common and
it also
brings I have a theory that a few people
have stolen but but there were these
pillars of of um of of wisdom or pillars
of just kind of moral or societal
pillars government
good big big government no but
they but again I'm talking about 100
years ago or or 60 years AG government
um
clergy and media and you could even
throw like business in there Y and then
they all
got
exposed through various means and fell
and then it became like like you know
who's pretty wise is that George Carlin
or that John Stewart or that or or Dave
or even like Michael Moore at a point or
Chris Rock or guys that are and women
that were Wanda and Sarah and like
people that were that are smart and so
then comedians become the kind of
pillars
of uh they they're de facto cuz
everybody else fell so but in our job is
just to be funny and like I don't think
Carlin was trying to be wise he just
kind of was but but we became the sort
of de facto weirdly kind of pillars of
wisdom and
morality and I don't think I'm wrong
it's I it's absurd but I don't it's
absurd but I think it's also maybe true
yeah and that's that's kind of worrying
as well that is worrying cuz look I love
com biggest comedy fan I'm a comedian I
don't know if I want a
comedian have that yeah it's like I was
Greg fit Simmons a buddy of mine
comedian and he's he's he started with
Joe and he's so we just talk about like
when the White House is getting mad at
Joe or CNN's talking about Joe Fitz
Simmons helped Joe steal his car stereo
back from his ex-girlfriend like just we
all have these stories of like Dave
Chappelle is a moral leader and I'm like
I've got
stories but they're all personal sto
it's just this weird thing of like them
okay it's it speaks to the same thing
about like what does it say about uh
American politics that that I'm willing
to vote for a corpse um but it's it I
now having said that I don't think Joe
and Dav are immoral or no but I I don't
think they're yeah they're human and I
think there is like a
there's a a learning curve where I
remember when when John Stewart was
being held up as a like a lot of people
were getting the news from him and he
was like I'm on after robots
fighting each other like I don't want to
be and like puppets making Crank phone
calls I don't want to be
the Arbiter of information and morality
but nobody else stepping up you know and
I would argue that perhaps in some ways
you could argue it's gone too far and so
like Trevor Noah for example yeah he he
does like lectures right he he what do
you mean in like in the world or in on
the show on the show yeah he will do a
whole segment about a very contensous
issue that people will see from
different sides depending where they are
there's not much humor in it quite often
and it's kind of like him giving it's
like a political sort of speech and and
I I don't necessarily blame him for that
I think there's a demand for that that's
kind of that's what you're saying we've
kind of got to a position where
comedians were like rust into this space
yeah it's funny when there's a tragedy
uh shooting
9/11 I think people
remember Letterman's 911 post 911
monologue and John's post 911 monologue
more than
Bush you know more it's like why am I
looking to Seth Meyers and Trevor for
leadership again these are guys that I
know very and I'm like I don't have like
again I've got stories I don't mean that
with d Joe it's just like they're very
human and they didn't move to New York
or LA to like I'm going to do some moral
leadership right ma pack my bet you know
it's like it's just a
weird you know abdication on the part of
all these other institutions and look I
understand these people are your friends
and whatever so this isn't me trying to
get I don't think you are no I'm not but
I've got another
question which is
um a lot of people particularly there's
a lot of people in the center center
right who would look at Trevor go oh
he's not funny I'm like I used to watch
his stand up he's amazing
Trevor again like I Trevor's
really funny however if I mainly
watch the moral lectures that I see
retweeted on Twitter yeah I would think
he's not funny sure and what I wanted to
ask you is and you know feel free to
answer anywhere you want I'm not trying
to lead you anywhere I'm just curious as
an outside Observer watching these late
night shows it feels to me disagree if
you want that they've lost teeth and
they've lost humor they're not as funny
and they're not as biting and they're
not as interesting to me am I wrong I I
know what you mean about their you kind
of know what the
uh what they're going to the area that
they're going to talk about what they're
going to say it's fairly
prescribed um I think it's a a
a market decision in
that it's it's the type of people who
come to the taping mhm you have to do
well yeah if I'm if I'm I would do The
Daily Show sometimes I wouldn't do that
well because they weren't really my
people so to speak um they so you've got
the type of people who wanted to come to
Seth any literally any Bill Mars tapings
um like they they they come to hear a
certain type of thing right well here's
sorry to interrupt I want to hear the
rest but here's where I might disagree
with what you're about to say which is I
think Bill what he's done is he's
actually shown leadership I what's funny
about Bill is he would bomb sometimes
and I saw it as
a
uh a good thing meaning like that means
you're doing something right right he
changed his audience over time that's
what he did because he was like I have
principles I don't like what's happening
with Co eventually I don't like this
woke yeah I'm going to take the
audience with me and I'm going to lose
some on the way yeah right but you're
saying in these other shows that that is
more difficult I well I was going to say
bill would complain if he would get ooze
sometimes so it's like I always thought
as good that he was getting Uso I always
thought like dude that's good that
you're not but that's the thing like as
comedians you want to kill right so yeah
of course um some of us can't
though um so uh it's always their fault
now uh so so I so it becomes the thing
of how am I going to do well on tape
right so then you're almost working
backward from like I tried this point of
view yesterday it got like nothing right
so then even or if you do a rehearsal
doesn't go well then you're like I can't
I don't want to say this cuz I'm just
going to eat right um so you've got
to feed that and then you just get in
this feedback loop of you say that it
goes viral feels good and then you just
get into that thing now having said that
knowing all these people none of them
are changing their point of view to get
likes or get
um virality like I can tell you I've
known Seth from before he hosted update
I've known Trevor from before he hosted
The Daily Show like they're not that
they Trevor's very naturally
reconciliatory um like it's just his
natural I always did a joke with him
he's like half black half white half man
half fish like he's just half like he is
walking reconciliation so I can
understand why that it's frustrating or
sort of kind of makes you roll your eyes
a little bit but I know where they're
coming coming from it's like Seth I
wrote for Seth on the correspondence
dinner it wasn't we made fun of I don't
the tone hasn't changed very much you
know he was we were one of again one of
the early making fun of Trumps but um so
I don't I don't think the tone I don't
think anyone's gotten the job and
changed their tone very much it's
interesting yeah and because you do see
all of these guys and again as someone
who is a disaffected liberal I go I
would just like some someone on the
right as well to be on a show and have a
little bit more teeth as well and I'd
like someone on the left to be like you
know what you are nuts and been talking
about their own side it would just be so
refreshing and actually it would also
make the shows more popular and it would
it would give them more relevancy
because I think that's what's happening
now the the more popular thing I can't
speak to like I don't I truly have no
idea I think what makes these shows
popular is Charisma and then celebrities
but um but the I think Mah does it
really well and I I watch Mar as
religiously as any of these other shows
but and then Greg Gutfeld has the fox
show that's apparently very popular and
more popular than coar and all these
other shows so
so yeah I don't know what they none of
them are lying and that's how I feel
about Joe whenever someone talk about
Rogan I'm like he is not doing this for
attention he's not he literally is like
oh it's the it's I'm curious or he
really is just a guy talking a guy
experiencing the world and broadcasting
it and as someone who used to do it in
his garage it's the same thing you guys
did it last week it's the same thing
there's just more
security a lot more that I completely
agree with you you know we did a three
and a half hour conversation this time
with Joe and then we went to see him at
the club later that night hang out in
the green room I mean what he's talking
about on stage is exactly the same stuff
he was talking with us in the green room
and it's exactly the same thing that we
talked about on the show it's very
authentic to and but people tried to
read a lot into it and I I certainly
wasn't saying that I think people are
pretending to have opinions that they
don't have it just feels to me maybe
it's the disaffected maybe I've got
older and become less liberal I don't
know but it just kind of feels a little
bit lacking teeth for me I I agree they
also have the the the
um the advertiser thing and again none
of them I've never seen or spoken any of
them about I need to worry about Proctor
and Gamble but there is they are kind of
there to get a rating that's that's they
have to get or they will lose the job
um so so I now but having said that I
don't think any of them
are
um steering the wheel toward
liberal
hegemony we'll be back with our guest in
a minute but first do you remember the
Canadian trucker protest in 2022 where
thousands of Canadians came out to
protest covid restrictions and vaccine
mandates now these protests lasted for
weeks and the people out on the streets
needed funds as any Grassroots protest
would so people set up online
crowdfunding campaigns which rais
millions of dollars incredible but once
the Canadian authorities had started to
criticize the crowdfunding platforms
ramping up pressure to close the
campaigns it didn't take long for the
biggest crowdfunding platform the one
we've all heard of to completely
capitulate and shut the campaigns down
now this is where our partners give send
go coming in they stepped in when the
other platforms backed off and raised
millions of dollars for the truckers
when they were criticized and dragged
through the Canadian courts GIF and go
said it respected diverse views and
believed hope and freedom are values
worth fighting for this is why we're
proud to partner with gifs and go so if
you need to crowdfund for whatever means
the most to you then don't go to the big
Tech platforms we recommend you do it on
give send go starting a campaign on give
Sendo is easy and intuitive go to giv
send go.com today that's giv send go.com
to start raising money for whatever is
important to you and now back to the
interview and are you excited
creative yeah you don't look good I've
never seen you look
excited um are you are you excited
creatively because it is a good time for
people like you who to play with this
with the tension that comedians always
play with with uh what are you looking
to create uh obviously standup specials
what what things are you thinking about
the only things that I I the only thing
I'm looking to create is uh just more
material that I my only the only my only
like prayer creatively is is uh
is a Rich Harvest I just want ideas and
I want jokes but I don't I having done
worked on Chapelle show for three
years it's so hard that I don't and I
help Trevor out on The Daily Show every
once in a while and it's just I don't
like the lifesty it's like very much
like an office job so um whereas this is
a house
job um yeah like I don't I don't I don't
I also
think that standup is the coolest thing
a person can do I just do like I and
that's having done a great TV show I
still that chel was good cuz it was so
stand upy to me um but the idea of
having to go to an office 40 weeks a
year and like backpack
and um the job of going and talking is
so cool and having no editor other than
yourself and the audience is such
a um it's a guys I'd say this it's a
blessing hash bless no it is it's just a
incredibly cool job it's I think the
thing which standup gives you and you
see with a lot of these guys it's a
freedom it's you're not answerable to
anyone you just go out there you've got
your audience you do your material that
you believe in that you've worked on and
that you will present and then it will
it will it will rise or it will fall on
its own merits yeah and and it's it's
uh if it's good it it lasts a long time
you know there are Bill Burr said to
Seinfeld on Comedians and Cars he was
like you've ruined so many things for me
meaning if like Jerry for instance or
Burr is another good example or Patrice
O'Neil are guys that like once you hear
something a certain way it changes your
perception of that thing forever you
know um like Patrice O'Neal has a bunch
of sexual harassment jokes that are that
are like defend
and it CH it changed my mind for I mean
or or it certainly locked my mind in or
or Burr has a bunch of those or like or
Dave or Chris or just there are people
that have can be can make definitive
things I just like it better myself I
watch pretty much every standup special
and I watch no sitcoms and I just never
really have I just don't enjoy them that
much I like sketch shows I like late
night and stand up why don't you why
don't you like sit comes you find it
contrived I just find it and I said this
to Jerry on Comedians and Cars like it
just they just seem to be like every
time I turned on they were worried about
a
jacket like where's the jacket it was
always just like what they're worried
about them we got to go over here just
it just it doesn't appeal to me yeah you
know I don't know it just doesn't like
that genre doesn't work very well have
you seen Peep Show no what I'm guessing
you have
yes uh no i s me has told me about Peep
Show for he's been telling me for 20
years about Peep Show genu I I've heard
no I believe it British said com much
better when I see Clips I'm like that's
funny but I don't I don't like
the I like bite-sized things yeah MH
okay which which is absolutely fair
enough so who are The Comedians for you
that influen you Neil that you looked at
and when you were coming up you were
like oh my God I would if I could be
half as good as them he obviously as as
mentioned
um
davel Dave Chappelle Chris Rock Brian
rean doesn't get enough credit he's an
amazing American comedian
um uh and then Burr
Patrice I'd say currently like Melania I
think is
excellent
um Wanda I think Sarah Sarah govern's
like been under I like cuz I kind of
grew I met her when I was 15 or
something so I never really and then a
couple years ago I was like she's
really good
um and then like Rodney kind of like the
one liner like Rodney Joan Rivers that's
sort of like did you guys see the Joan
Rivers documentary no there's a
documentary about her where you watch it
and you go oh I will never say a bet
like has index card like libraries full
of jokes that she's collected and
written for 50 years like people that
work hard uh
are like that's a different category but
it's still it's it's a big uh it means
you know it's like it's a hard job like
you have to you have to really grind at
it so and I'm sure I'm forgetting 15
people but of course you are you always
are when you talk about
the hey watch your
tongue um and what was Hicks like by the
way to work with him to I didn't I just
met him once so I he was just kind of
like after a show the interesting thing
about it is I it was at a club in New
York and it was H he was there for the
weekend Thursday through Sunday and I
went to the Sunday show and it was like
2third empty wow and this is six months
before he dies so this thing he was big
in the UK but he was still like largely
unknown in the states yeah you can't be
a profit in your own Homeland as they
say correct as they say as they say yeah
the new it's been a pleasure great this
is totally painless well you know what
before we go to local inflict some pain
yeah why do you watch
trigonometry um or listen to it do you
watch or listen it's hard to
watch um I cuz I like the I
like
heterodox
ideology um I like
hearing the
opposite argument for a thing that I've
just eaten
up like I enjoyed like Douglas Murray
books I like seeing
somebody I like
watching mcer
bomb it's F it's meaning I respect it he
MC's not but I mean generally douas
muray and John War uh go to the go to
places where they don't bomb but but
they're they're not doing themselves any
favors um by they're not uh Towing the
company line and it it feels more honest
like a podcast like this it is truly
like you're willing
to
um discuss things that it's the you know
someone's like that's a controversial
topic life's
controversial the whole thing is
controversial so the fact that I'm
supposed to pick aide and never question
it or talk about it is insulting
so I I
enjoy um
hearing even opposite points of view I
just like that you guys are willing to
talk about it and and have people talk
about stuff and not and you are
disaffected liberals like you are um
it's one of you more than the other we
establish but but like I I can relate to
that point and and I don't mind it's the
I don't know who it is Aristotle or
somebody like that uh it's the sign of a
advanced mind that you can entertain two
ideas at once I'm I'm butchering it like
you guys butcher my but um but at least
he's dead um so he doesn't have to be
here to watch it um uh but uh but I mean
we did
put thing is I thought I was going to
help but I actually realized as I was
saying you made the same
mistake my mistake was slightly smaller
but the fact that I also made a mistake
made it much worse I mean this that's
basically the show as well is I it
up he tries to help and then just as bad
just as bad a different way yeah um so
so I like uh you're I basically feel
like you said like do you think we're
pretty why why do you watch our podcast
cuz I like hearing opposite points of
view and it it feels like a way of th
thumbing my nose up at uh
more entrenched liberals you know I
didn't ask you that question although he
going to make a great clip to
promote trigonometry right obviously but
I asked you that question because I
think you are exactly the sort of person
that we're trying to reach when we do
what we do which is somebody who
understands that the world is complex
and we're not it's not just about
reaching people like you cuz you're
there with us really but there are lots
of people who who maybe they just their
feed whatever is they're being fed isn't
feeding them a Nuance conversation it's
feeding them you know bumper stickers MH
right and all we're trying to do is take
the bumper sticker and get some
interesting people and go why don't we
just zoom zoom out a little bit and go
what else what else is there why why is
this thing controversial why are people
disagreeing about us what because by
definition controversial issues are
issues on which many people have a
different opinion mhm and that's because
people's psychology is different their
genetics are different their life
experiences are different um all sorts
of things their cultures are different
and that's why they need to be talked
about in a sensible way so it you know
genuinely gratifying to me to hear you
answer that yeah and I don't it's funny
me and Jimmy Carr would send each
other maybe like a a dougas Murray clip
or or like a Jordan Peterson clip again
Jordan Peterson I'm still trying to find
the controversy I'm like what I still
don't understand the problem look at his
Twitter well yeah I heard he's but but
uh but but um no I agree you know what I
mean he's making very good and very
important points and um and and like
yeah how dare he tell boys to make their
bed um the uh the but like we would send
each other clips and it felt like we
were sending each other like red fox
records or something or like dirty
filthy blue comedy it's like uh it's
like blue ideology and it's just a
little bit heterodox or like I don't
know maybe also this it's also I've also
accepted a long time ago that like if
this many people are conservative there
must be something to it like I again I
can see where I can't just go they're
all out of their minds I'm assuming that
it's comes from a genuine place I love
those studies where they'll they'll show
like uh they more psychological studies
where like conservative people are more
averse to watching people vomit have you
seen those things where it's like these
weird psychological links between
conservatives and liberals and like I do
think it's that deep I really do like it
it and it's and it's you can't even I
think you they'll be able to tell like
in utero who's going to be conservative
I mean you're this one of the
interesting things about uh this idea
that you're political iCal opinions
determine whether you are a moral person
or not right I mean obviously at the
extremes that is true to some extent but
it's like 50% of your political views
are predetermined by your genetics yeah
so so go oh you think like this that's
because you've chosen to be
about also like you're not we're not
choosing almost any of this stuff no
yeah it's like you know as as what's Sam
Harris doesn't even believe like we're
we don't make any decisions yeah yeah I
mean I have I have some issues with that
I do too but I'm just say it's like okay
I get I see how you came to that yeah no
but you're right I mean conservatives
they crave order uh they have a much
lower discussed threshold the discussed
thing drives them a lot more it's why
they find certain things they can be
much more hard line about things because
of that because it's like like that and
liberals they Crave You Know openness
and compassion and much of what we're
seeing I feel is like compassion but
that's been weaponized and it's just
gone out of control people and it's also
I always see it as like
compassion Without Limits and it's like
you know there's got to be some we need
a whenever people bring up immigration I
go how many people should we let
in what's your number and they never no
one ever ask that you just go no no
what's the what's the right amount what
to you is the right amount and there's
dishonesty on both sides where it's like
we can't have any and it's like well
then the economy is going to dry
up if we don't have any or we have as
many all you can
eat um which are they're both they're
both bad policies yeah so
but I don't I will say there's not I
don't think there's very many of me so
don't get your hopes up in terms of
people that are I'm a pain in the ass
like I've been a pain in the ass that's
why like right no but I'm saying that
makes me a good comedian but I don't
think there's a lot of people that are
um uh like when you guys like you're
hoping to get people like me I don't
know that there are many again I could
be wrong but I I think that there are
more people that are hopefully and maybe
there will be maybe there won't be but
more people willing to question things
be like what is the what why what
is like let me watch some Jordan
Peterson and see if there's an issue
here and then you watch them and go I
don't see an is whatever so I but I
don't think most people are willing to
uh and they don't have the time cuz I
don't have a wife or kids so I got
endless time um but you know
it's people have people are busy and
they are more willing to just go what's
the what opinion am I supposed to have
fine I'll just put that name tag on and
not question it because I don't have my
wife's going to yell at me if I if I
watch so many videos I mean it's very
true Neil what a pleasure final question
as always what's the one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be
bed bugs no I'm kidding um
um I it's
the I would say it's the the
decision-making process that we all
[Music]
are going through which is like these
are we can have split decisions or have
uh mild
majorities there I have mild majority
about pretty much everything and I wish
people would stop pretending that it's a
everything is a
100% held belief I just think it's
dishonest you're going to have to leave
La in order to get that oh well then I'm
then I'm I'm gonna have to live with it
because I love I love this city um no
yeah I I'm with you but but I
think there's it doesn't require a ton
of Bravery it's just a matter of like eh
or just assume it about most people
instead of it it also makes arguing with
people more um
Humane and you're it you don't you don't
sort of brand them immediately as like a
zealot like I'm not a zealot about too
much I can be persuaded to believe
anything I kind of believe that though
like I I'm not I'm not
um I think assuming zealotry from other
people is uh and I I you hate to bring
up Israel but it's a good example of
like whoever the last person to talk to
me is I believe I'm on their side you
know what I mean I'm just like okay I
then I yes it was an occupy NOP that was
wrong and like just going back and forth
and and not
knowing I don't I have no I don't
know for most issues I the more you
investigate it the more con the more
confused the less convinced you are yeah
finally you've gotten my material uh
yeah the more the more you investigating
the more you investigate something the
more confused you become yeah there's a
great PA well lyric which goes the more
I know the less I understand we got kind
of nailed it on that Neil you know what
I I always say this because it's my job
but I really do mean it it's been an
absolute pleasure of a conversation I
look forward to hearing what our fans
want to ask of you on locals which is
where we're going to go next so head on
over there and we'll continue the
conversation how do you write
[Music]
you